[Música]
é preciso uma aldeia inteira pra educar
uma criança
dizem até que essa criança tenha
necessidades especiais
esse é o limite esse provérbio bonita
africano que se usa tanto hoje quando se
toca nessa maternidade especial na
maternidade que ninguém quer ninguém vê
e todos têm medo de falar sobre a gente
cruza uma linha importante e do outro
lado a aldeia se desfaça
segundo a onu 1 bilhão de pessoas no
mundo têm algum tipo de deficiência 1
bilhão
dos sete milhões e meio que somos todos
vocês sabiam disso
eu não sabia há cinco anos atrás eu não
sabia muitas das coisas que eu sei hoje
por uma razão bem simples
eu não precisava saber eu nunca quis ser
mãe nunca me achei capaz de educar outro
ser humano com a responsabilidade de
ensinar para ele aquilo que eu mesmo não
sei nunca achei que eu era boa o
suficiente para o cargo em de usado das
mães
mas a vida sempre foi meio do nada
comigo e com 22 anos e nenhuma vontade
eu engravidei e sentir a conexão mais
potente da minha vida começar um
processo de gravidez eu toquei muito com
meu companheiro na época a gente tinha
muitas dúvidas sobre quem é o nosso
filho seria agente debateu tudo todos os
tabus que a gente encontrou pelo caminho
a gente falou sobre afeto atuação
entrega
falamos sobre uma educação feminista e
igualitária
pensamos em como abordar íamos assuntos
como sexualidade raça privilégio
pensamos também que faria você esse
menino que estava chegando no mundo
quisesse ser
artista de circo ou tivesse uma opinião
diferente da nossa política
gostava de música sertaneja a gente
pensou em diversidade mas de forma
incompleta
nunca pensamos que aconteceria com a
gente seria um outro desafio que
chegaria tão cedo e que quase
perderíamos o joão
eu que sempre tem a certeza que meu
filho teria amor e espaço
mas eu não sabia o que tava pra ver
então quando joão tinha 1 ano e 8 meses
ea essa altura o sol o meu sol e corria
por tudo e falava bastante e se
aprontava muito o corpo dele colapso do
nada
a doença grave e muito violenta que hoje
a gente conhece nos pegou desprevenidos
numa virada de esquina
no domingo a gente estava no parque
pulando na cama elástica se divertindo
na segunda entrada no hospital de onde a
gente demoraria 71 dias para sair
eu lembro ainda dá a sensação de estar
sendo levada para a uti
e naquele momento ter certeza que a
nossa vida nunca mais essa é a mesma já
foi diagnosticado com uma doença rara e
sofreu um grave avc
é muito difícil falar sobre isso ainda
hoje
porque são essas coisas que a gente não
espera que vão acontecer na nossa vida
o diagnóstico parecia uma ficção
científica o nome da doença chuva e eu
não conhecia
é uma doença raríssima e muito fatal e
até dez anos atrás tinha uma taxa de
mortalidade de 100% e era isso que
estava acontecendo com o meu filho ele
estava morrendo 71 dias muitos desses 71
dias ele estava morrendo e por isso
quando ele sobreviveu
as sequelas do avc era uma parte do
problema que estava disposta a enfrentar
foi assim que o mundo totalmente
estranho das necessidades especiais
começou pra nós e joão se tornou parte
dessa minoria gigantesca de 1 bilhão de
pessoas
foi assim que a cadeira de rodas se
tornou a forma dele de navegar no mundo
e eu aprendi a ler olhares e gestos e
precisa - das palavras os meses da volta
para casa foram devastadores
joão não controlava mais o próprio corpo
ele não sentava ele não falava ele não
comia ele não andava
as melhoras eram pequenas e muito
graduais
o tempo tinha outro ritmo eu tive que
aprender a dançar mas a ficha só caiu
mesmo na volta pra escola quando numa
reunião de pais para explicar a entrada
do joão na turma uma mãe ignorou a minha
presença se virou professora e disse meu
filho pequeno de mais para conviver com
esse problema e esse problema era o joão
com dois anos meu filho deixou de ser um
menino pra virar um problema e passou a
saber o que é não ser desejado cedo
demais
um dia uma médica me disse
o cérebro é sagrado ainda tem muita vida
pela frente umas mil possibilidades
no meio de tantos diagnósticos péssimos
e nossos medos e as nossas inseguranças
e um reencontro com a sociedade tão duro
eu não sei dizer de onde a gente tira
tanta força mas eu sei dizer uma coisa
sobre as palavras ditas com o afeta
elas têm o poder de quatro entradas
por tempo indeterminado e assim passaram
cinco anos cinco anos de tratamentos
intensos de reabilitação nos exigiram
muito esforço muito estudo e muita
coragem cinco anos assistindo joão
tentar no paço dele voltar a conversar
com o próprio corpo e passar de todas as
barreiras que disseram que pra ele
seriam impossíveis
ele aprendeu a sentar liberou as
mãozinhas de novo que hoje em mogi ama
um desenhar ele encontrou de novo
caminho das palavras que são poucas hoje
ainda mas que mudaram o nosso mundo fica
de pé milésimos a mais a cada mês que
passa a soprar a primeira série em tempo
regular e é esse menino amoroso corajoso
e muito inteligente que faz parecer
fácil o que não é
ele faz parecer é fácil porque o joão
tem um movimento muito natural de deixar
a dor vim e não se abraçar nela e uma
alegria que a mais honesta que eu já
conheci e é o modo operante que ele
escolheu de estar no mundo
toda vez que alguém descreve o caso do
joão como milagre
eu me lembro que esse milagre foi ainda
é feito de muito suor e falou na vida
dele baixinho quanto o mergulho do
menino que ele se tornou há alguns meses
atrás eu comecei um processo de estudo
para escrever um livro sobre inclusão
começa a entrevistar outras mães e
profissionais da área do jogadores
nessas entrevistas um assunto voltava
recorrentemente me incomodava a solidão
das mães ditas especiais
não que eu não tenha sentido a solidão
em nenhum momento muito pelo contrário
eu acho que a gente sente tanto que se
acostuma
mas eu estava ignorando o assunto aquela
velha coisa de botar nossos problemas
pra baixo do tapete e pensar depois
outra hora em quem sabe amanhã é preciso
uma aldeia inteira pra educar uma
criança mas nos nossos casos na maioria
das vezes o que temos são amigos que não
querem se aproximar
parentes que têm medo e não querem se
envolver
tios que não vou levar essa criança para
passear nunca num sábado de tarde mas de
colegas que não convidam para dormir na
sua casa convite de aniversário que não
chegam a voz que dizem não ter mais
idade mas que estão mas não muito mais
que vou embora olhando profundamente a
verdade é que muitas vezes a mãe é
alguém inteira dessa criança e ela vai
tentar ser com toda a força dela e ela
vai se esforçar se cobrar para dar conta
de todos aqueles papéis e ela vai falhar
invariavelmente ela não tem nenhuma
chance
esses tempos recebeu um convite de
aniversário de um colega do joão
era uma festa do pijama dessas que tem
as cabaninhas e as crianças dormem na
festa
eu gelei porque já em mim saber que pro
meu filhos convite são diferentes e eu
não respondi para a mãe
demorei dias deixei passar aquele prazo
de confirmação para a festinha e os dois
dias antes da festa eu procurei ela
mandou uma mensagem escuta voa
acho que vou levar o joão pelo menos
para que ele fique três horinhas com os
colegas que ele possa estar com os
amigos num momento de celebração e
depois buscou ele não vai rolar domina e
ela me respondeu
cito topa' eu queria tanto para que ele
dormisse
eu fiquei meio chocada porque não
esperava a resposta dela
quantas mães no lugar dela estariam
dispostas
nós decidimos juntos tampar o joão não
voltou para casa naquele sábado ele
aproveitou muito estava feliz e muito
bagunceiro disse que comeu bastante
cachorro-quente derrubou várias
campanhas por gosto e rolou para dentro
de reuniões secretas das meninas sem
autorização e foi o último a dormir
feliz naquela noite eu me sentir uma mãe
normal grudada no celular acorda de
madrugada inteira cuidando para ver se
algum fenômeno da natureza tirado meu
celular quebrou o silêncio
o uso mas normal e esse dia me ensinou
muitas coisas sobre a normalidade do meu
próprio filho sobre como medos nos
impedem de viver experiências
importantes sobre a minha coragem a
coragem do outro que quando se encontram
podem ser tão potentes
sobre ter uma rede disposta a fim de
tampa inclusão parece uma palavra
difícil um movimento grande que cabe a
grandes esferas e se ensina e livros
complicados mas a verdade é que a
mudança acaba na mão de cada um de nós
na escolha de pequenos gestos com
gentileza da empatia pela dor do outro
numa abertura pela diversidade como um
todo
precisamos mudar o nosso ponto de vista
entender que lugares são deficientes
idéias são deficientes
o marketing eo planejamento design é
deficiente e não as pessoas e
ultrapassar barreiras óbvias por afeto
as pessoas me perguntam por onde eu
posso começar você já olhou a calçada
hoje você conseguiria atravessar ela se
estivesse numa cadeira de rodas
esqueçam as vagas prioritárias nem por
cinco minutos
nem por cinco segundos elas não foram
feitas pra vocês foram feitas para um
bilhão de pessoas lembra pergunta na
escola do filho de vocês qual o
posicionamento sobre inclusão uma escola
que não tem capacidade desejo de olhar
para as diferenças gritantes do meu
filho não vai ter sensibilidade para
olhar para as utis do seu meu convite
vai além sejam aldeia sejam rede
sabe aquela amiga que tem um filho com
paralisia cerebral liga para ela hoje
pergunta como ela tá com disponibilidade
para escutar
parece simples mas não acontece
raramente ou aquela mãe de um coleguinha
que tem uma doença rara convida para o
parquinho pega essa criança no colo
tentou olhar com alguma normalidade às
vezes não é tão ruim
diferente inclusão não é um favor é um
processo de melhora do mundo para todos
é entender a diversidade como força e
não como fraqueza é buscar soluções de
ensino de trânsito de olhar de
convivência que abracem todas as pessoas
como elas são
respeito que subestima não respeita a
pena inclusão pra mim é olhar para as
diferenças do outro
respeitar as diferenças do outro olhando
de igual para igual
nós já passamos de muitas fronteiras da
nossa história
já ultrapassamos muitas que desumaniza
hram o joão que tiraram ele da caixinha
do perfeito tiraram a vida caixinha do
bonito do aceitável para resumir em uma
cadeira de rodas o problema aliás por
favor nunca resumo uma pessoa há
problema
vocês correm o risco de essa pessoa
acreditar nisso
por outro lado em contrapartida essas
mesmas fronteiras nos fizeram crescer
muito nos desumanizando nos humanizaram
muito mais foi recebendo olhares tão
duros que eu consegui olhar para o outro
com mais candura e ultrapassando linhas
improváveis e outras impossíveis que eu
achei a felicidade genuína porque não
precisa esconder a dor a gente sente
frágil quando precisa pedir mas a
verdade é que toda mãe precisa de uma
rede e é preciso uma aldeia inteira pra
educar uma criança
toda criança mesmo aquela que diz eu te
amo
apenas com um olhar eu queria dividir
uma coisa que vocês agora
para finalizar faz cinco meses que o
joão voltou a me chamar de mãe
ele conseguiu mama na verdade eu fiquei
muito tempo sem essa palavra sem esse
lugar e agora a gente estava fazendo uma
viagem uma das nossas muitas viagens e
ele me deu esse presente aqui eu queria
dividir
i
ah
nós somos a diversidade sejam aldeia
sejam a rede
obrigado
[Aplausos]